the press versus Sara Sanders that's the
focus of tonight's angle yesterday the
White House press briefing turned into a
total feeding frenzy on spokeswoman
Sarah Huckabee Sanders the White House
press corps is up in arms over the
discrepancy between what she told the
press previously that the president had
no knowledge of the payments made to
stormy Daniels and what Rudy Giuliani
revealed this week you were in the dark
I think it's actually several times now
they give you the best information that
I had and I'm going to continue to do my
best to do that every single day
familiar Trump enemies join the anti
Sanders mob have we ever gotten any
truth out of them have they become to
the point where not only as she lost the
room but they've become null and void
but she's lying to the American public
and I think she needs to own that being
ignorant or lying about it it's just not
an excuse there's no comment a better
option well I think not having these
brought why not not have the briefings
if you're just going to lie why bother
this is how democracies die slowly right
in front of us every single day
deception and lies become normal how
dramatic Mike Mike Barnicle this is how
the magazine dies oh please then under
the headline why Sarah Sanders should
quit that subtle crystal Liza writes on
cnn.com to the extent Sanders retain
credibility among the White House press
corps she lost it with that answer
admitting that you misled the press
because the president misled you is
tantamount to taking your credibility
pouring gasoline on it and then setting
it on fire people just aren't good
writers either well these people are
going to lecture us about credibility
the press consider the sources as Brian
Staedtler might say or actually didn't
how he how he cursed is the one who
first said that are these reliable
sources for the most part the White
House press pool has become a pack of
lupine look
commentators and their activists
masquerading as journalists just listen
to this she can be mad of what I say
right now tough you know I'm a reporter
who's going to continue to ask questions
and there was nothing wrong with that
question and I wish I could install a BS
meter inside the White House briefing
room
unfortunately thing could be going off
all the time and it would be hard to
hear the press secretary attempt to tell
the truth on a daily basis I think she's
very resourceful like she burns facts
and then she uses that Ash to create a
perfect smoky eye I literally had to
turn my volume down on that last Oh a
little bit
well the effort to demean and drive out
Sanders and send her out packing from
her job it's part of the politics of
personal destruction in this town
Washington DC anyone who works for the
president is a target because the
resistance wants to thin the ranks of
those in the administration and advance
a narrative of internal division and
chaos and at the same time Sarah Sanders
she's in a very difficult position and
she has to look out for her own
credibility as well she was given scant
information and she repeated what she
was told and I think she did it in good
faith frankly all questions about this
investigation should have been referred
to the president's legal team period
Trump needs a legal spokesperson which
he doesn't have at this point
issues pertaining to an ongoing
investigation should not be addressed by
the White House press spokesperson and
despite the chiding by Jim Acosta
Sanders can't be brought on on these
legal discussions without of course
becoming a witness herself there's no
there's no privilege and she should get
herself and any type of legal pickle she
doesn't want that so it is right
for the legal team to have kept Sarah
Sanders in the dark on these sensitive
topics for her own protection and this
is why I've always warned against
arguing your case in the press
it's tempting I know you want to respond
to everything but it is too fraught with
complications and it's very easy to make
a misstep but
said do not presume that these
journalists are disengaged bystanders
trying to keep it real
they have proudly many of them become
hostile adversaries in the vanguard of
the resistance it's gotten so bad that
reporters are now engaging in full-out
intimidation of the White House press
folks even threats of physical violence
again here's April Ryan from yesterday
why didn't he was taller the White House
press office about his impacting stellar
statements about what was happening the
White House press office wouldn't
coordinate with the president's outside
legal team on legal harem is on you said
yourself only blindsided I actually
didn't use that term why I said it but
you work wise not knowing what you say
well for a while with all due respect
you actually don't know much about me in
terms of what I feel and what I don't
want you have is operating for Sarah
Huckabee Sanders the presidential
spokesperson the mouthpiece for the
president United States to say you don't
know me in certain quarters in this
nation that starts a physical fight I
was very shocked
it was Street I will even go beyond that
it was gutter you know what gutter is
this Twitter exchange between April Ryan
a White House correspondent and the
former Democratic mayor of Baltimore
Stephanie rawlings-blake Blake writes
April Ryan unsolicited comeback
suggestions for press secretary I may
not know you but I damn sure know ally
and you're wearing it's it's all over
your face oh wait is that smudge in your
liner uh-huh huh Ryan then responds on
Twitter
lol stop be more in the house I know you
have my back that you don't know me
stuff begins fistfights
she needs to know what she is saying I
am not the one Blake then tweets back I
already took my earrings off and
Vaseline in my purse and you see the
fist emoji there and that's nice then
April Ryan tweets back again that's what
I'm talking about
take off that pretty ring to the
whatever she says
fight lol this is gutter and a gutter in
need of a little editing apparently but
it's Twitter but can you imagine if
someone on this network started taking
off their earrings could I take mine off
and and said take off your pretty ring
and let's have a street fight with our
political opponents it would be instant
Armageddon you know what they would do
they would say we were what inciting
violence so they said the other night
about i'll ben ben shapiro right he was
inciting violence because he tweeted
something but these journalists feel
protected and free to threaten and
slander members of the Trump
administration with abandon their shared
hatred of the president and those who
represents unites them no matter what
they do or say and they think they can
do it with impunity
Miz Ryan has a history of these
aggressive tactics remember she was the
journalist who hazed Sanders last
Thanksgiving suggesting that that didn't
really she didn't really bake that pecan
pie that she tweeted a picture out of
and she also regularly engaged and
inflammatory encounters with the former
press spokesman Sean Spicer and put my
urn back in I appreciate your agenda
here but the reality is oh no no hold on
no at some point report the facts the
facts are that every single person who
has been briefed on this subject has
come away with the same conclusion
Republican Democrat so I'm sorry that
that disgusts you you're shaking your
head it seems like you're hell-bent on
trying to make sure that whatever image
you want to tell about this White House
sees well truth be told April Ryan's
been tough on some Democrat press
spokesman over the years as well but
here is the reality
journalists are our representatives in
the halls of power and their job is to
ask substantive questions and get real
answers they're not there to be
perpetual critics or naysayers with the
recurring role or partisan bullies if
you want to raise your profile by
staging viral confrontations with public
figures do it on your own time get a
podcast or be a regular pun
on MSNBC but if you want to be a
journalist and prattle on about
credibility why don't you start by
trying to restore your own and keep
those rings in your purse and the
Vaseline put that away
that's the angle